delicious poached pears ready so we
gonna poach them with a little bit of
chili chili never heard of a little bit
of saffron no no no panel take off a
little slice on that so they stand up
nicely and then peel okay man and then
the chili you hold that up I just go
down yeah through and open that up okay
into the water seeds in as well
so poach these pears a little bit of
chili water and sugar
what are they horse exactly saffron is
expensive but you only need the tiniest
little bit a little pinch to make that
water go light golden star anis all that
flavor coming out the chili we're gonna
make the most amazing star nice dust
dust get your star nice in there seed up
and then in two little seats and then
you start grinding a little teaspoon of
ginger give her a nice mix thank you
mate and that's gonna dust the top of
the pears once they're cooked right get
your pears drop them in there
and that's what we're gonna sprinkle in
ginger it's doing these dresses they're
very good monster cooktop pulldown
sprinkle that over the top right have
you guys got homework yes okay thank you
guys are from eight-minute simmer our
pears should be ready no just hit your
life on the knife throw is now easy the
knife is so that means they're soft
then cooks now you can't even in that
overnight twist three days and they just
get darker and more beautiful a good
thing about the cooking liquor is that
you don't throw that away because you
can use that again for reproaching
beautiful and they look impressive the
smell delicious Donna lemon
look at the colors nice lovely isn't it
those are amazing
no just doesn't and then take your
little star nice dust and just dust over